[Intro]
Have you ever felt
out of place in this world
or feel like you never
truly belonged anywhere?
Do people usually think
you are odd, eccentric,
or describe you as
having the head in the clouds?
Don't worry.
This doesn't mean
they're insulting you.
In fact, take it as a compliment.
If you're identified with any of any traits,
it means you are creative.
To understand your mysterious
talents and elusive nature,
here are 7 signs you're a highly creative soul.
1. People often call you playful.
Playfulness is a trait
that is usually looked down upon
because people associate it
with immaturity and unreliability.
But did you know that
there are actually many benefits
to being playful?
It turns out that those who are playful
get better grades in school,
can handle stress better,
and are more motivated in life.
According to a study,
those who have a playful nature
are naturally more creative,
because they can easily change perspectives.
This allows them to be
effective problem solvers
as they stumble upon
unusual and novel solutions.
So the next time someone founds
upon your childlike behavior,
remember that
your mental flexibility is a strength
that helps you overcome challenges
while letting you have some fun.
2. You're a night owl.
Do you often stay up late?
According to the research
published in the journal personality
and individual differences,
it turns out that
those are night owls
tend to find more creative solutions.
In fact, night owls scored higher
on three creativity tests
than early birds.
Experts believed that
the reason behind this,
is because their unconventional
schedule and habits
may encourage them to find alternative,
and out-of-the-box solutions.
So the next time your parents
tell you to go to bed early,
tell them that
you're just being creative.
3. You get distracted easily.
It turns out that sometimes,
too much focus can distract
you from being creative.
In stead of concentrating too much
on one specific part of a picture,
creative souls tend to drift
here and there,
exploring different options and ideas.
Researchers also discovered that
creative achievement is associated
with one's inability
to filter out sensory information.
So if you're sensitive to
constant tapping, loud chewing,
talking or outside noises in general,
it's because your brain
has trouble ignoring them.
Although this sounds like a nuisance
when you want to get things done,
the upside is that
you're prone to being innovative.
4. You're neurotic.
Do you feel often stressed out
or worried more easily than others?
The good news is that your neuroticism
makes you more creative!
Although the anxiety you experience
can make you unhappy on a daily basis,
According to research,
the part of your brain
that is highly active
in your neurotic individuals,
is also responsible
for self-generated thoughts.
While neuroscientists don't
understand the direct link
between neuroticism and creativity,
They believe that
the active part that triggers neuroticism,
is also related to our imagination.
5. You're good at coming up
with lies, stories, and excuses.
Sounds crazy
and a bit over the top, right?
But according to a study
done by Professor Gino Francesca
at Harvard Business School,
and author Dan Ariely who wrote
"The (Honest) Truth about Dishonesty",
there was a correlation between
dishonesty and creativity.
This is not to say that
every creative person
prefers to lie, cheat or steal.
But it's because their active imagination
that makes them superb storytellers.
Francesca and Ariely state that
creative people
subconsciously convinced themselves
that their actions are justified.
Interestingly enough though,
creative people usually don't believe
that they are dishonest.
Because their imagination convinces them
that what they think is real.
6. You have a messy room
and work environment.
This doesn't mean a gross workplace
that is unpleasant to be in.
But one study
published in sage journals,
shows that disorganized
desk and environment
can promote creativity.
Researchers conducted three experiments
to see how messy rooms
affect people's creativity.
They concluded that
disorderly environments
can inspire the individual
to break free from tradition,
which encourages them
to produce novel ideas.
Organized environments however,
influence people to play at safe,
take less risks,
and think inside the box.
7. You enjoy talking to people
from all walks of life.
Creative individuals aren't afraid
to go out and meet people
who can give them new ideas,
and refreshing perspectives.
They like to be experimental,
and welcome things
that are less traditional.
This makes them resilient
as they have
a high tolerance for failure,
if it means embracing
exciting new experiences in exchange.
To boost your creativity,
we'd recommend that
you talk to people who
challenge what you think you know.
Which of these signs
do you most resonate with?
Comment them below
and if you feel they're accurate.